I'll now introduce you to the concept of
a random variable random variable and
for me this is something that I always
had a lot of trouble getting my head
around and that's really because of it's
a byproduct of what it's called it's
called a variable and we're used to
variables well you know that as kind of
an unknown in an equation if I write X
plus 3 is equal to 7 the variable was X
maybe you could solve for it or maybe
you could have an equation y is equal to
3x minus 2 and then here Y and X are
both variables if you input 1x you could
solve for the other variable Y and if
you you can change them and variables
were kind of things that could change
and that that you could solve for and
they could take on particular values a
random variable is kind of the same
thing and that it can take on multiple
values but it's not something that you
really ever solve for so just so you get
used to the notation a random variable
is usually a capital letter usually
capital X wires usually capital X and
weird really differs from a traditional
variable is that it can take on a bunch
of different values like a traditional
variable but you never solve for it and
really it's a little misleading to call
it a variable at all it's really a
function and it's a function that maps
you from the world of random processes
to an actual number so let's say I don't
know I wanted to somehow quantify a
random process is it going to rain or
not tomorrow so let's see rain tomorrow
rain tomorrow no rain so you could
observe that you could wait until
tomorrow and see if it rains or not but
then how do you quantify it well we can
define a random variable that will
quantify we can say this random variable
is going to be equal to 1 if it rains
tomorrow and equals 0 if it doesn't rain
tomorrow we didn't have to assign 1 and
0 those tend to be a little bit more
useful they make sense but we could have
assigned this as I don't know we could
have said that this is 21 and this is
100 it's however you define it so it's
important to keep this distinction in
mind that a random variable it isn't a
variable in the traditional sense of the
world it's more of a function that map's
us from the world of a
random process to a number and then this
number is going to be random right
because we don't know if it's going to
rain or not tomorrow maybe we we have
some sense of the probabilities so this
variable can take on either value and
that leads us but let me let me draw a
couple of more random variable
definitions just so you get get it very
you get the intuition that these really
are functions so we could define a
random variable X is equal to well
actually I let me know it could just be
a very obvious numeric mapping it could
just be the the number number facing up
when I roll a fair dice back that's a
random variable I could have also said
it's the number of most facing east when
I roll a fair die although that's a
little e is less useful you could also
define a random variable X is equal to
you could say it's equal to 1 if I get
if heads and I could say 0 if tails or I
could have done it the other way around
once again once you get these heads and
tails or outcomes of an experiment right
when I flip a coin that's a random
process each flip is a is a is an
experiment and then the random variable
is just quantifying that experiment so I
know it sounds a little technical with
the terminology but what we're really
doing is fairly something simple we're
just assigning a 1 if we get ahead 0 if
we get a tails and the random variable
is just that function mapping now I'm
going into all of this you know random
variable business which I didn't do
before when we did probability because
it does start to become a little bit
useful notationally because we'll start
to talk about things like probability
distributions and expected values and it
really is useful to to quantify things
as a random variable and with that said
let's let's talk about probability
distributions and expected values so if
their first thing probability distribute
i p-- sum and embarrass you can have
discrete random variables discrete or
continuous
continuous so there's two types discrete
would be like really all of the
definitions that we had up until now the
role of the role of the flip of a coin
you're either going to get a 1 or a 0
there's two discrete cases when I roll a
die there's one of six different
outcomes I can have whether it rains
tomorrow there's one of two outcomes yes
or no so in all of these situations you
have you could almost say you could have
a countable number of outcomes a
continuous random variable it could take
on an infinite number of outcomes so
continuous random variable will be the
exact it could be x is equal to the
exact amount of rain in inches tomorrow
now why is this continuous right well if
you think about it that could take on
any of an infinite set of values you
might have one inch of rain tomorrow or
you might have one point 1 inches of
rain you might have one point 1 1 1
inches of rain you might have two point
1 1 1 1 inches of rain as you can see
you could just you can come up with an
infinite number of combinations of the
amount of rain you have and you get
exact well I'll go into more of this
when I talk about probability density
functions but in general even though you
might say oh well you know I can't
imagine having an infinite amount of
rain because you know we're not going to
have a hundred gallons of rain tomorrow
but if you think about you could take on
any value between one and two inches of
rain
there's actually an infinite number of
values between 0 & 1
right there's for any value could you
could find a number that's a little you
know one just to think about it between
0 & 1 1/2 is in between those and you
can always find a number that's halfway
between those and then a number that's
halfway between those there's an
infinite number of numbers between any
two numbers while with the discrete
random variables it just took on a
finite number of values those ones up
here it could only take on 1 or 0 it
didn't take on one point 1 and it
couldn't take on infinity and I make
that that difference because actually
how we look at it in terms of their
probability distributions are a little
different but they're they're very
related so a discrete random variable
like the ones that we defined at the
beginning of these videos they have a
probability distribution so let's let's
let's do it for and let's say X is equal
to the the number facing up number
facing up on a fair dice fair dice so we
already know that to get each outcome so
there's you know there's one there's six
outcomes you're thinking two one two
three four five or six facing up so
let's draw the probability distribution
so here all the outcomes I'll draw that
on the horizontal axis so the at one
outcome is one two three four five six
and then in the y axis or in the
vertical you plot what is the
probability of each of those outcomes
occurring what's the probability switch
colors so what's the probability of
getting a 1 what's 1/6 right so if I
draw 160r one-sixth so the probability
is of each of these occurring no I
didn't want to do it like that
r16 it's essentially like a histogram or
bar chart and it's just going to be each
of these my intention is to draw them
all the exact same height right so this
is telling us that each of these there's
a 1/6 chance of it occurring if I were
to draw a probability distribution for
if I were to find the random variable X
is equal to 1 if heads 0 if tails this
has a very simple probability
distribution see there's only two
outcomes you're either going to get a 1
or 0 and then in the y axis you'll have
the probabilities
and each of these if it's a fair dice
it's going to be a 1/2 probability and
you're going to draw a little box like
that that tells you each of them or 1/2
now let's say you had another I don't
know probability distribution function
that looks something like this those are
kind of very run-of-the-mill examples
but what if I had something like this
let's see where I had some dice let's
say it had some weird weightings on it
where it had an outcome of you know one
I had a 1/6 chance like that let's say
for some reason a 2 could never happen
let's say maybe there is maybe there is
no - let's say 3 has a 1/6 chance of 4
has a 1/6 chance a 5 has a 1/6 chance
and let's say there's two sixes right
like we erase the 2 when we put a 6
where the that 2 is so there's two sixes
so the six has a 2/6 chance so the six
would be a 2 6 chance so now I think you
can see where the probability
distribution function starts to become a
little bit more interesting right and
the other ones it was kind of a what we
would call a uniform distribution all of
the outcomes are equally likely that's a
uniform distribution once again this is
a uniform distribution this one all of a
sudden is not a uniform distribution one
is just as likely as 3 4 5 2 is
impossible to happen but 6 is twice as
likely to happen as everything else is 2
6 so if you if someone gives you a
probability density function or if they
give you a little chart like this you
can immediately say what's the
probability of different events
occurring right so if you said that X is
equal to the number on on unfair dice
that's described by this probability
distribution function then if I were to
ask you the probability that X is equal
to 6 you'd say oh the probability x
equals 6 is equal to 2 6 or 1/3 right if
I were to say what's the probability
that X
the random variable X is given by this
definition is greater than five you
would take well let's say greater than
or equal to five right because you want
that you want to include five and at
least I did so it would include this
situation and this situation so it would
be 1/6 plus 2 6 it'll be 1 6 plus 2 6
and so you could say that's 1 you know
that's 3/6 or 1/2 so it gets pretty
interesting once you know you don't have
a completely uniform distribution and
I'm doing all of this because in the
next couple of videos well 1 will move
away from discrete and actually study
continuous probability distributions
which are called probability density
functions and then we'll go to study
kind of a lot of distributions that show
up in nature the uniform distribution is
one of them there's also the binomial
distribution and the normal distribution
which is a lot some people call the
Gaussian or the bell curve which is kind
of a very common thing but anyway I'm
all out of time and I'll see you in the
next video